l'histoire du jour les fourmis de feu
arrivent en France qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces conneries
après les punaises de lit les moustiques
tigres voilà maintenant des fourmis de
feu carrément en France comment ils
faire face sont-elles dangereuses
pourquoi sont-elles
prendre le pouvoir sur l'humain
notre spécialiste qui vient nous voir
très souvent romain la soeur
expert en espèces invasive
c'est à dire que même si quelqu'un veut
vous piquez votre femme il est expert
Gilles tu devrais le consulter il va
répondre à toutes nos questions regardez
un petit récap sur les fourmis de feu
quel apparences sont-elles ces formules
de feu il y en a-t-il parmi nous toutes
les questions que tu poses
après les moustiques tigres c'est un
autre insecte qui risque bien de nous
envahir la fourmi de feu derrière ce nom
inquiétant se cache la c'est le nautisme
Invicta une espèce originaire
d'Argentine qui ne mesure qu'un
centimètre mais qui peut avoir de
lourdes conséquences sur l'environnement
et dont la piqûre peut être très
douloureuse
si ces petites bestioles aussi appelées
fourmis électriques avaient pour leur
épargné notre continent elles viennent
d'être découvertes en Sicile mais aussi
en France la fourmi de feu fait partie
des 100 espèces que l'on considère
invasif qui pose le plus de problèmes
dans le monde alors les fourmis de feu
arrivent en France faut-il avoir peur
romain la sœur et là et les fourmis de
feu arrivent on en avait pas sur vous
et ben c'est un peu planqué mais là je
serais tout à l'heure alors il paraît
pourquoi cette fourmi est plus-elle plus
inquiétante que les autres bah c'est une
fourmi qu'on connaissait pas en Europe
elle vient d'arriver parce que c'est le
11 septembre quelles ont été découvertes
en Sicile à Syracuse 88 ni implantées
donc ça veut dire qu'elles sont déjà
arrivées depuis un petit moment il y a
notamment des gens là-bas qui se
plaignaient de piqûres déjà depuis un
certain temps alors contrairement à
toutes les fourmis qu'on connaît en
France on ce qui mordent principalement
et qui projette ce qu'on appelle l'acide
formique en fait elle suce c'est ça
alors elle mord elle mord comme les
autres fourmis en fait alors elle elle
pique en fait elle pique avec un dark ou
même système que la guêpe d'accord et là
et pourquoi fourmis
de l'abdomen en position abdominale et à
la différence de plein d'autres fourmis
qui pour se défendre projet de l'acide
formique donc l'acide le nom de l'acide
formique vient de la découverte de cette
assiette qui est projeté par les fourmis
et qui crée des inflammations à la
surface de la peau elle elle pique
et la piqûre elle est hyper douloureuse
quoi en venant il est brûlant c'est un
venin brûlant il peut même pousser des
gens à faire des chocs anaphylactique
quoi donc
[Musique]
ça c'est pas de l'acné c'est
effectivement des piqûres
pour faire ça bah en fait la
problématique c'est que elle vivent en
colonie donc les colonie de fourmis de
feu c'est à peu près 4 à 500 000
individus donc ça peut être ça peut être
sur des grandes surfaces et quand elle
s'en prennent à une proie parce que faut
voir aussi que cette fourmi à la
différence de plein d'autres fourmis il
faut quand même se dire qu'on a à peu
près 15000 un peu plus de 15000 espèces
de fourmis dans le monde et on en a que
quelques unes qui posent des
problématiques parce qu'elles viennent
dans nos activités donc le reste des
fourmis ont un rôle à jouer dans la
nature qu'on connaît notamment de
pollinisation d'un certain nombre de
fleurs et d'arbres donc les fourmis
globalement elles ont un rôle très
positif dans la nature et parce qu'on a
des activités humaines on en a quelques
espèces comme celle-ci et le notamment
une autre de ses cousines aussi qui
s'est fortement installée en Corse avec
donc
encore c'est il y a des campings
complets en Corse qui peuvent plus
ouvrir parce que il y a des colonies
entières de formule et donc en fait dès
qu'elle vienne en contact pendant les
vacances tu restes pas de Ken hein alors
ça je sais pas j'ai jamais été piqué
faut y aller en chaussettes quoi mais
c'est un peu relou mais on pouvait pas
les détruire on peut pas les détruire
alors la problématique et c'est ce qui
fait peur aux scientifique arrivé pour
la première fois en Europe en tout cas
détecter en Italie alors la présence
française elle reste à confirmer
première arrivé ce 11 septembre là en
Italie et ce qui fait peur aux
scientifiques elle a une capacité à
coloniser les territoires très très
importantes on estime en Europe il y a à
peu près 7% du territoire qui pourrait
être colonisé dans les 10 à 20
prochaines années et il y a 50% des
villes européennes qui peuvent être
colonisées parce qu'elles vit en ville
donc elle s'adapte très bien au mode
urbain et comment elle se disséminent
alors avec ces petites pattes bien sûr
mais surtout que les reines pendant le
vol nuptial prennent le vent
et vont se poser plus loin et fonder une
colonie plus
et du coup c'est comme ça que
l'expansion des colonies se font et donc
il leur arrivée du à quoi c'est
réchauffement climatique
alors je me prononcerai pas sur ce sujet
là
non clairement comme plein d'espèces
Invalides on en a parlé la dernière fois
avec le moustique avec la punaise Delhi
c'est nos modes de vie et nos modes de
transport elle elle suit les cargos et
dès qu'elle est en fait comme Axel baume
donc et donc en fait on découvre des
nids pas très loin des ports donc ça va
ça va se disséminer avec les graines de
gazon les céréales qui les qu'on
transporte c'est vachement discret
container exactement et c'est super
discret et une fois que ça une fois que
c'est implanté ça devient très invasif
pour alors un petit chiffre on la
connaît déjà dans plein d'autres pays
les US
l'Australie Taïwan la Chine il y a plein
de pays où elle est déjà implanté c'est
des milliards de dollars qui sont
dépensés tous les ans lutter contre ça
typiquement ah bah non on les a pas on
les a pas typiquement aux US c'est 6
milliards par an pour les faux
rien pour lutter contre ça parce que
nous les nous on a plus d'oseille
ce qui est pas évident c'est reconnaître
une fourmi une espèce de fourmille d'une
autre c'est pas simple alors on disait
il y a un expert qui disait un
centimètre en général elles font pas
plus de 6 à 7 mm donc petite fourmi et
puis malheureusement maintenant que tu
t'es pas fait piquer avec une piqûre
très douloureuse très douloureuse
enfin pour les enfants le choc est plus
alors le choc il est plus dangereux il
est plus dangereux avec cette espèce là
qu'avec les avec une morsure d'une autre
fourmi ça c'est sûr et on a
effectivement des mammifères et des
oiseaux qui meurent de la de la peinture
et ce que je voulais dire tout à l'heure
oui ce qui est en fait quand elle
s'attaque à un animal clairement quand
vous passez derrière cette espèce une
colonie de cette espèce qui a plus rien
à diversité et pour les chiens et les
chats hyper dangereux chat hyper
dangereux
donc en fait et quand elle s'attaque à
une proie elles sont capables de
l'arranger jusqu'à l'autre c'est clair
et elle elle émettent dans l'air une
phéromone qui alerte le reste de la
colonie qui vient se déplacer et qui
viennent les aider non allez pas donc
c'est super bah c'est hyper organisé
c'est les animaux sociaux qui vivent en
coloris 500500000 individus dans une
colonie ça fait beaucoup donc clairement
premier point l'identifier comment on
fait si on en a à la maison pour leur
leur race
non alors
comme toutes les autres espèces quand on
les s'en aperçoit c'est quasiment déjà
trop tard un moustique aujourd'hui c'est
72 départements depuis 20 ans si la
fourmi de feu arrive en France
probablement au moment où on va s'en
apercevoir elle aura déjà colonisé
discrètement plein de territoire on fait
quoi on ferme sa gueule et on non je
pense que si on a des doutes en tout cas
en cas de piqûres très douloureuse faut
informer les informer les les autorités
pas réussi à l'éradiquer sur l'île alors
en milieu insulaire c'est toujours plus
facile d'éradiquer quelque chose plus la
plus on fait comment c'est facile bah là
malheureusement si elle s'installe en
France on pourra pas les radiquer c'est
mort on peut pas y aller en France on
est mort
à côté le temps qu'on réagisse
malheureusement alors réagir c'est quoi
c'est réussir l'identifier en informer
les instances sanitaires aujourd'hui il
y a notamment le Muséum d'histoire
naturelle qui bosse beaucoup en France
on est toujours en retard surtout on va
pas être en avance sur les fourmis au
feu on peut pas on peut pas isoler les
mâles et les castrer pour pas qu'ils se
reproduisent ben alors écoute il nous
fait une séance et puis on vient d'avoir
la problématique parce que là vous venez
vous angoissez tout le monde et vous
apportez
des solutions
c'est que vous dites que c'est
urbain donc dans les villes on imaginait
ça plutôt dans les campagnes
ça peut bouffer des champs complets
il a dit des animaux mais c'est vrai il
a dit les amis
vous voyez bien qu'on vit dans une
société dans laquelle on vous fait
comprendre que les insecticides c'est ça
le faux puis en utiliser le bio machin
truc donc clairement sur des sujets
comme ça oui ça bouffe les animaux moi
c'est pour les animaux que ça me fait
plaisir
les chats salut les chiens un chien
entre 8 et 20 kg ça ça va pas forcément
s'attaquer une fourmi qui est très
agressive vivant bah potentiellement ça
s'attaque à plus gros que soi quand tu
es en colonie de 500000 tu as pas de
sujet et s'attaquer un petit chien ça
peut s'attaquer à des petits mammifères
et tuer des oiseaux également donc on
peut tout imaginer l'idée l'idée c'est
pas c'est pas de repartir de là de
manière très
anxieuse
non alors moi j'en ai pas c'est clair
plus tu comprends la bestiole moins tu
as d'espoir sur les espèces invasives
malheureusement
non mais la problématique c'est pas ça
c'est que notre métier c'est d'informer
d'informer c'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui ça c'est d'informer que
c'est là on peut pas on peut pas le nier
et il faut l'identifier au plus vite
prévenir les instances sanitaires il y a
des professionnels en France bah
l'identifier il y a des il y a des
instituts de leur parler ce sont des
insectes plus peur que les punaises
ça va beaucoup plus vite
on a dans les plages au Cap d'Agde les
nudistes
elles vont pas là-bas il y a trop de
maladies elles vont pas là-bas
elles vont pas là-bas elles vont pas
là-bas c'est effectivement notre métier
c'est d'informer de dire bah elle va
probablement arriver en France si elle
arrive il faut qu'on mette tout en oeuf
pour essayer dans d'enrayer ça parce
qu'elle est plus dangereuse elle arrive
à moi aussi
bon ouais international Genève vous nous
expliquez que donc on est en veille par
les moustiques tigres à longueur de
semaine maintenant les fourmis les
punaises de lit on a l'impression qu'on
est complètement démuni il y a pas une
stratégie encore sur les punaises il
était plutôt
optimiste sur les fourmis de feu il a il
nous dit si vous avez des fourmis de feu
c'est terminé rideau non c'est pas ça
c'est que malheureusement pour faire
quoi voilà moyenne va faire quoi mais
malheureusement les gens en ville
souvent il y a juste tu vas faire quoi
voilà ils sont 500000 je fais 1 2 3 4 5
c'est terminé voilà je pars comme ça il
y a 500000 morts
la problématique c'est que ces espèces
elles mettent une pression permanente
sur nos sociétés sur la vie on se rend
pas compte c'est qu'il y a des
professionnels qui bossent dans l'ombre
et qui régulent ces bestioles et on a
l'impression qu'on vit dans un dans le
meilleur des mondes mais il y a un
travail de fond qui est fait par les
professionnels
en France qui fait que on arrive à
enrayer tout ça veut dire vous avez dit
qu'aux États-Unis c'est 6 milliards le
budget pour combattre juste pour les
premiers de feu il faut
impact sur la biodiversité impact sur
l'agriculture impact sur les structures
impact sur les animaux
on va faire quoi
n'y voyez pas sur le sujet que c'est un
outil de biocontrôle en tout cas ça peut
pas tuer un homme c'est même avec un
choc
il y a des gens qui peuvent y rester on
peut il y a eu des morts aux États-Unis
en Australie ces documenté et dis-moi
c'est mais elle nous annonce la fin du
monde tu es en train de nous dire que
les fourmis de feu vont conquérir le
monde
c'est des espèces qui sont tellement
implacables dans leur manière de se
disséminer elles utilisent nos moyens de
transport
elles sont collectives hein
que les industriels vont trouver des
produits pour les indiquer un produit en
Europe c'est maintenant si on a niche
chez soi on fait quoi on appelle les
pompiers non les pompiers il faut
absolument informer informer votre
commune informer La Mairie frère tu
crois qu'on a un nid tu crois que je
vais aller voir le maire excuse-moi j'ai
un nid de fourmis de feu là
je peux te voir 2 minutes
j'ai un nid de fourmis de feu là la
maison là
tu as des solutions toi ah non mais
frère elle va me dehors je fais
quoi je les défonce mais malheureusement
en France le vrai réseau d'altère
je vais les chercher sous terre non la
meilleure des solutions c'est de faire
intervenir un pro pour qu'il calme le
truc on a des professionnels on a une
chambre syndicale en France qui
s'appelle la cs3d sur laquelle son
référencés professionnels des
professionnels alors on appelle qui
peuvent intervenir aujourd'hui on a des
on a des on a des produits qui marchent
très bien ils font quoi alors justement
on a des produits
alors c'est pas l'ancienne image de la
sulfateuse où on passait avec un 4x4 là
ça finisse nous il y a des solutions il
y a des solutions c'est des gels
alimentaires c'est des cartouches de gel
que les fourmis consomment avec à
l'intérieur j'ai matière active parce
que autre particularité des fourmis
c'est qu'elles communiquent par trop
fancine donc la trophée elle s'échange
du matériel végétal et du matériel
alimentaire et à cette occasion alors
qu'elles ont mangé du gel elles vont
s'échanger de la matière active et avec
quelques fourmis qui vont consommer le
gel on va on va pouvoir éradiquer
[Applaudissements]
les professionnels aujourd'hui vous avez
des tas de blocs sur Internet qui avec
des remèdes de grand-mère qui met du
fioul avec de l'eau de javel des machins
ça fait que retarder le problème parce
que ces espèces là elles rigolent alors
l'intervention ça dépend de la grandeur
de la colonie ça dépend de la surface
traité par le professionnel mais ça peut
aller jusqu'à 1000 euros c'est un bon
business à développer c'est un super
business
et toi tu le fais ça toi tu le fais non
non c'est pas nous on participe à
l'innovation dans ces produits
la société dans laquelle je bosse pas
les fourmis de photos si on fait on va
on va former les professionnels sur ces
nouvelles espèces ça c'est notre métier
c'est une fourmi de foot attaque et ben
tu mets un pare-feu comme ceci ici là
ici et je rappelle que contre ça contre
ça il y a ça d'accord c'est une fourmi
eux peut vous prendre dans les yeux
comme ça ça passera pas alors on va
essayer tu vois mais non mais toi tu le
fais toi ouais on propose des boules
quand même à gagner à chaque fois c'est
pas mal les services
c'est vraiment de faire monter les
professionnels
encore c'était encore
à Marseille dans deux semaines sont
partout ça y est elles sont là elles
veulent non mais d'autant qu'à la
décharge des autorités sanitaires c'est
super compliqué de contrôler les
marchandises qui vont et viennent bien
sûr
donc là
on va essayer de tout mettre en oeuvre
de former les professionnels à cette à
cette nouvelle espèce pour que on puisse
être efficace et faire un rempart quoi
bien sûr bah tu as bien raison bravo à
toi merci en tout cas romain d'être venu
et nous avons mis